la société dans le collimateur depuis
mon diplôme donc je me vois toujours ici
dans dinner tout en continuant à
m'éclater dans mon travail bien sûr
évidemment le petit sourire pétillant
qu'elle est pile au bon moment non très
bien très bien et dans 20 ans eh ben on
en reparle dans dix ans si vous voulez
bien mais c'est dégueulasse
ah c'est sûr c'est plus facile quand on
est belle tiens les pas de pitié
question piège d'une petite semaine mais
je vous en prie neige les abris
parfaites là allez vas-y poussé à la
faute alors si je vous donnais un
million maintenant que feriez vous
l'argent n'est pas une fin en soi
moi c'est ça c'est une récompense bien
venu évidemment mais c'est pas ce qui
m'anime mois ce qui m'anime c'est le
challenge données online chez réponse à
tout je sais raisonnée quoi cela et si
vous pouviez acheter un cerveau 9
tiens lequel choisiriez-vous c'est très
intéressant moi je sème et bien je
changerais rien parce que la réussite ça
n'a aucun rapport avec le cerveau en
fait qu est ce qui vient des tripes et
clément agissante et là si j'appelle
votre ancien patron qu'est ce que dirait
de vous mais je vous encourage à le
faire sur quatre autres le moment n'ont
pu se mettre en décapant pour elle aussi
d'en juger sur son physique que pense
qu'il dirait deux mois que je suis une
personne contact facile et ça fout la
génétique
ce que dit peu qui à bord de son prendre
plein la gueule et si vous étiez à ma
place quelles qualités recherchées riez
vous chez le candidat à ce poste est
bien celle que je viens de décrire
justement elle me
[Musique]
je pense qu'il vous faudrait aussi
quelqu'un de posé quelqu'un de réfléchi
qui sait résister à la pression vous
imaginez comme vous comme j'imagine oui
pas fait ce que vous le dites merde
j'espère qu'elle pense pas qu en train
de draguer la non non non non non non
non non mais je sais pas comme tous ces
gros lourd là qui recèle les jolies
filles mais non c'est autre chose
elle m'inspire elle mais si ça ne
m'inspire rien vous demande encore une
petite seconde
je me sens bien avec elle quand vicat
parts
allez je regarde un peu ici en rouge
abuse fond qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ce
test de personnalité ou un test de qi
difficile suis là je vous épargne et je
sais alors ça c'est juste une petite
fiche à remplir c'est un micro tests
psychotechniques avant de pousser plus
loin le gaza soit sur le bureau
voilà stylo là quelque chose en plus
cette fille
j'ai pas envie de la séduire c'est plus
ce m j'ai envie de la peindre mais oui
voila j'ai envie de la peindre
bon je sais pas peindre mais j'ai même
pas besoin d'apprendre ça me vient comme
ça
voilà je reçois le don de peindre rien
quand on le regarde il ya quelque chose
que vous comprenez pas cette partie
peut-être
c'est pourquoi